[Música]
a
escala en parís braulio moro
bienvenidos a escala en parís una
emisión de radio france internacional en
colaboración con la televisión france24
en español vivimos un mundo en el que
todo parece acelerarse la toma de
decisiones la circulación de la
información y de la contrainformación y
asimismo de los conflictos y en paralelo
actúa el mundo de la mediación una
actividad que requiere mucha capacidad
disuasiva en varios países la figura del
mediador existe sea laboral social
familiar jurídico esto se desarrolla de
manera cada vez más general para
hablarnos de esto saludamos aquí en
nuestro estudio a marianela sánchez
abogada bienvenida marianella valera
muchas gracias antes se presenta como
experta en prevención gestión y
resolución de conflictos en las
organizaciones es así embargo leo muchas
gracias la gestión la prevención y la
resolución de conflictos es hoy una meta
competencia que tienen que tener todos
los líderes y tomadores de decisiones en
este universo que como bien describiste
al principio es necesario contar con
habilidades comunicacionales que
permitan transmitir mensajes claros pero
concretamente en qué consiste ese
trabajo de mediación y de resolución
prevención de conflictos la mediación es
uno de los métodos para resolver
conflictos no es el único mi experiencia
es bastante amplia yo soy mediadora de
la corte suprema en argentina en una
provincia en tucumán y esto me da la
oportunidad de entender que no todos los
conflictos se solucionan con el mismo
método la mediación prejudicial es una
mediación previo a todo proceso judicial
donde ya las personas están de acuerdo
en que quieren ir a esa instancia y la
mediación es una instancia de un tercero
colabora en esa gestión de conflictos
justamente en este caso cuál es una
experiencia concreta que yo estoy tenido
en la corte de justicia de tucumán
generalmente la mayoría de los casos que
se presentan son de sociedades o de
familias donde el cambio comunicacional
que permite un tercero neutral que puede
replantear toda la situación desde una
posición diferente a cómo ven las partes
hace que esa comunicación sea más fluida
y existan posibilidades de acuerdos no
siempre la mediación termina en
resolución sin embargo la figura del
mediador cambio toda la dinámica
comunicacional que venían siendo hasta
ahora para el conflicto hace parte
intrínseca de nuestras sociedades y como
señalaba en principio efectivamente en
un mundo donde las cosas se aceleran más
ese conflicto desborda pudiéramos decir
de manera cotidiana la situación cuál es
el papel en ese caso de una persona que
trabaja precisamente en la prevención y
en la gestión de los conflictos el
conflicto en ser en dentro de las
organizaciones es una figura que viene
específicamente a capacitar a los
líderes en las metas competencias
necesarias que tienen para gestionar a
las personas tenemos dos conceptos
importantes en esta realidad que estamos
viviendo la inteligencia colectiva que
genera saber trabajar en colaboración a
los líderes no son responsables de las
tomas de decisiones y de buscar
soluciones tenemos que buscar de manera
colaborativa llegar a esos procesos pero
no sin antes entender de qué se trata el
conflicto
contextualizar lo hacer un mapa de
quiénes son los integrantes cuáles son
las relaciones y cuál es el contexto en
el cual vivimos presunto terreno
dijéramos muy movedizo por un lado usted
habla de líderes entonces esto siento al
mismo tiempo la sociedad tiende a buscar
más la horizontalidad de decisiones es
la jerarquía lo que permite ya la figura
del mando y obedezco no existe sí aunque
empezamos a buscar a partir de la era de
la colaboración que será mucho en este
mundo de internet donde las personas
crean un programa y varias personas lo
mejoran ya no importa quién lo crea sino
todas las soluciones que potencian y
mejoran eso creo que la sociedad ha dado
vista en este nuestro contexto que no
salimos solos e individualmente con
resultados sino que es la colaboración
de todos lo que genera soluciones
colectivas un conflicto manager capacita
a los líderes en que puedan visualizar
esto que confíen en sus equipos la
pandemia la pandemia del coronavirus
precisamente ha servido de cuna de
fertilizantes para que desarrollo se
desarrolle una serie de conflictos
notablemente las prohibiciones que ha
habido esto ha causado cada vez más
conflictos que es muy difícil gestionar
precisamente cuál es la experiencia que
usted desaparece la experiencia es que
parecen difíciles los conflictos hasta
que podemos desarmar los desarticularlos
una vez que desarticular
desarticulamos esta situación podemos
entender cuál es el foco a dónde tenemos
que prestar atención generalmente los
conflictos a partir de la pandemia
comunicacionales cuando no hay un
mensaje claro que genera genera hacia la
persona que lo escucha sentimientos
emociones que desbordan en acciones que
a veces no son las que se espera que
coincidan entonces una de las
principales características es comunicar
efectivamente para que el resultado que
busco en la otra persona en el otro
grupo sea el que realmente necesito y
creo que en esta pandemia lo más
importante fue trabajar en la
tranquilidad en la paz en saber que no
sé bien a dónde vamos pero estoy
buscando todas las herramientas para que
vayamos al mejor destino posible hay un
punto de comunicación sin duda alguna
que es importante pero también hay un
punto de transferencia de dijéramos
imparcialidad cuando uno se aproxima a
un conflicto cómo hacer para mantener
ese equilibrio en situaciones como los
que hemos vivido en la pandemia donde la
gente siente que le están prohibiendo
cosas al mismo tiempo se requiere que
como colectivo se actúe en un cierto
sentido en este sentido de visualizar la
situación como esta inteligencia
colectiva que genera si nos esforzamos
todos los resultados serán para todos en
los esfuerzos individuales no nos llevan
a ningún lado de hecho es cuando
entendemos que podemos juntos salir
adelante lo que nosotros podemos avanzar
como sociedad somos la única especie que
en sociedad puede avanzar de manera
consciente y colectiva a diferencia de
las otras especies entonces creo que en
esta pandemia la neutralidad la
imparcialidad pero sobre todo ha sido la
empatía lo que ha permitido que luego de
tanto tiempo podamos de alguna manera
visualizar la luz al final del camino y
al mismo tiempo estamos en una sociedad
que cada vez jala más hacia el
individualismo
héctor de plantear enormes desafíos como
mediador como gestores de conflictos
exactamente en la mirada hacia el otro
se torna a veces compleja y más en una
situación de conflictos donde entendemos
que lo que nosotros queremos siempre es
diametralmente opuesto que lo que el
otro quiere creo que el conflicto nasser
otorga las herramientas para tener en
cuenta que ese proceso comunicacional
puede derivar en necesidades conjuntas y
colectivas que no necesariamente son
contrapuestas cuando existe un conflicto
las emociones que rodean ese conflicto
nos impide ver efectivamente lo que
nosotros necesitamos y lo que el otro
necesita un tercero se plantea eso en
términos de posibilidades y permite
evolucionar hacia un método adecuado de
resolución de conflictos a la mediación
es uno pero existen la negociación
exista el arbitraje existe la
conciliación son varios y el abanico de
posibilidades mucho creo que los líderes
en las organizaciones que han sido los
grandes tomadores de decisiones en esta
pandemia
tienen que saber cuáles son también las
soluciones tal vez no llegue a donde
pero el diagnóstico eficaz de dónde está
ese conflicto y cuáles son las
posibilidades que tenemos de resolverlos
de cuentas acuerdo a las herramientas
que tenemos es fundamental en ese
propósito de marion de la mediación
arbitral que el liderazgo suena mucho al
trabajo que hacían hasta hace poco los
sindicatos en qué medida un mediador
pues del trabajo que usted desarrolla su
planta el papel precisamente de
organización sindical que el trabajo que
tenían el sindicato tiene una
característica que es va por el interés
colectivo de una parte entonces cuando
existe un conflicto está muy bien su
papel porque su papel es de alguna
manera mitigar el conflicto de poder que
puede existir entre un trabajador y una
empresa el mediador que hará el mediador
el conciliador la persona que está en
esa negociación necesaria porque
evaluaremos cuál es la necesidad lo que
va a hacer es equilibrar el poder que
existe sobre la mesa si ahora bien en la
situación actual y esto desde hace ya 20
años por lo menos asistimos a una cosa
que es nueva que es la selva de lo que
son las redes sociales redes sociales
que son difíciles de controlar redes
sociales que influyen en la sociedad en
ese terreno el papel de ustedes como
mediadores como gestores en dónde se
desarrolla el odio hay mucho anonimato
cómo puede actuar un mediador de ese
terreno el mediador tiene que transmitir
una comunicación eficiente por suerte
las leyes nos acompañan para poder
entender y poder poner límite a este
abuso de alguna manera en lo que es la
intimidad y lo que son las otras
personas sin embargo cuando pasamos a la
instancia judicial de una situación como
ésta de alguien que haya difamado a
alguien en internet es tal vez el
mediador es tal vez el conciliador quien
puede otorgar a esa persona que difame
en redes sociales la mirada de cómo se
siente el otro cuando le sucede eso que
no la tenía porque cuando somos anónimos
lo podemos hacer ahora cuando pasamos
una instancia judicial somos denunciados
y estamos sentados en esa mesa una
sentencia no siempre resuelve un
conflicto una sentencia lo que hace es
declarar un derecho a establecer una
obligación exactamente sin embargo un
proceso comunicacional como puede ser la
mediación o cualquiera que se dé lo que
permite es hacer entender al infractor
el impacto de su
conducta en la otra persona comentábamos
usted está especializada en la
resolución de conflictos de las
organizaciones en su trabajo en su
experiencia usted participa notablemente
como mediadora y como mediadora de
tenedores de inmuebles cuando hablamos
de esto hablamos de solamente de
vecindad de cercanía de personas que se
entrecruzan de caracteres muy diferentes
háblenos de los 12 experiencias sobre
este terreno los conflictos hong kong en
la vecindad son los conflictos juntos
con los de familia bastante complejos
porque vivimos con la persona y con el
vecino del lado por lo tanto las
diferencias o las fricciones no nos
llevan a ningún lado y es mejor procesos
comunicacionales que juicios porque
recoge muy sencillos que no son muy
sencillos por eso en argentina por lo
menos antes del juicio vamos a esta
instancia de diálogo que es la mediación
la vecindad termina siendo no más que un
conflicto como cualquier otro que
necesita ser replanteado en término de
necesidad generalmente los ruidos
molestos la invasión del espacio privado
en las mascotas suelen ser puntos de
interés de toda la vecindad sin embargo
conversando
es fácil replantear y poder entender las
soluciones que podemos gestionar juntos
y usted que es fácil realmente es fácil
he tenido la magia de ver he tenido la
magia de ver cómo cambia cuando podemos
puedo intervenir cuando los mediadores
podemos intervenir en esos procesos
a partir de que el otro pueda comprender
que la posición de no quiero que haga
ruido va abajo de esa de esa sentencia
hay algo más necesito descansar porque
trabajo todo el día cuando podemos
trabajar desde ese lugar el diálogo
cambia y las miradas es mágico cuando se
puede trabajar en cualquier conflicto en
la organización en los conflictos
familiares en los vecinales en los
penales hay una área muy grande y muy
interesante de promoción de estos
métodos marianela cuáles son algunos de
los escenarios a venir precisamente en
la resolución de conflictos bueno muy
bien vos te adelantadas esta parte en
internet todos los conflictos derivados
de las nuevas de las nuevas formas de
comunicación que con ese anonimato
parece que no tienen no tienen fin des a
los países han avanzado
acciones que permitan eso entonces los
mediadores debemos los mediadores y los
gestores de conflictos debemos estar al
día con esa tecnología que viene a
generar conflictos que antes no
conocíamos importante tener en cuenta
cuando hablamos de conflicto hablar de
manera conceptual con el otro para que
entienda mi mismo lenguaje entonces lo
que tenemos que saber desde desde el
punto de vista conceptual hablar del
conflicto con la terminología que
corresponde en 20 segundos que sucede
cuando el papel del mediador no funciona
le habrá sucedido de manera muy breve es
así los mediadores no tenemos soluciones
a todos sin embargo nuestra
participación cambia la dinámica del
conflicto y solo eso pueden cambiar
muchas veces situaciones que parecían
que no se solucionaban nunca los
mediadores tenemos una responsabilidad y
los gestores de conflictos más aún y
dentro de la organización es nuestro
objetivo pues llegando ya al final de
esta escala en parís no me queda sino
agradecerles a marianela sánchez a su
presencia aquí en esta escala de parís
gracias por haber venido a ustedes les
damos una nueva cita la próxima semana
en otra escala en parís
[Música]